played bishop six just saying you know
what again throw all clash for the wind
just just
attack attack attack attack attack and
this is actually very reminiscent of how
like
uh dania daniel neroditsky likes to play
against he plays sort of attacking ideas
and just hope that it works i'm gonna
write him a message that's very nice of
him
i appreciate that very much
[Music]
we're gonna look at the first blitz game
magnus is playing black here against
ikaro who is white
magnus is black hicario is white
no all gm's can play blindfolds i'm i'm
almost as good blindfold as i am
in over the board so hikaru played the
f4 line
which which is the
definitely the most how should i put it
the most topical line in the hello kind
it's the
it's the attempt to refute it on the
spot but
magnus actually came very prepared um
against this
against this line and i don't want to
delve too deeply into the opening
theory here which i don't even know
myself but i do know that what magnus
played
this line of bishop f5 and e6 is
considered to be one of the main lines
and he develops this other bishop to its
most active square
now obviously the point is that at some
point he wants to take on c3
and damage white's pawn structure and
then go after this pawn on c4 by taking
on c3
black prevents white from potentially
later on playing b3 to reinforce the
pawn
so it wouldn't make much sense for
example to go right after the spawn like
this because
white would simply have b3 so that's why
it's necessary
here to give up the bishop c5 undermines
white's center i'm pretty sure this is
well within the bounds of theory now d5
is very tempting
but of course you have to pay attention
to the pin
and the pin eliminates a defender on the
pawn so black can even take it with the
queen
um which means that ikaro has to play a3
if he ignores this and castles well then
magnus takes
and then all of white's pawns become
demolished so he car doesn't want to
allow that he plays a3
um magnus takes cicara takes
and magnus goes knight c6 now
you might be puzzled by the fact that
the c5 pawn is hanging
but you know these are what i call irish
pawns
or what they call them the charlotte
chess center irish pawns also known as
triple punts
i don't even know where that comes from
but
even if white can cling to these pawns
which she can't because they're
they're forked this is not a pawn
structure that you want to
get even in return well in return for a
measly pawn so hikaru
very sensibly castles magnus castles
e3 and a c captures a g4
c captures a d4 and here uh we would
like to pause the video
uh you can't i'll talk tal uh bishop
bishop e3
knight a5 kuvian a4 chapters
captures capture sculptures capture
sculptures um
this does feel like a nimzo indian in
fact this has shades of the armageddon
game which i'll talk about later
okay so bishop e3 by hikaru reinforcing
the
d4 pawn which makes perfect sense
and magnus's move makes perfect sense as
well knight a5 he's got to go after the
spawn that's his only idea
hikaru defends it with knight to d2
lending reinforcements to the pawn
and magnus drops the bishop back to g6
that's actually prophylaxis
this move might seem mysterious to a lot
of people but could somebody tell me
what this is prophylaxis against what
what is this prophylaxis against
like and what i mean by prophylaxis is
he's preventing
a threat that hikaru has posed what is
that threat
and it's a positional threat it's not a
tactical threat
well queen h5 is illegal because of the
bishop
g4 is not really a big threat because
then he could drop the bishop back
yeah d5 is the unpleasant move so if we
just played h6 after d5 take a look at
white's pawns and how strong they are
white wants to push them out to d6
and once he establishes a pawn on d6
well that's going to be a splinter in
black side
therefore we play bishop g6 so that
after d5 we could take
and the bishop does not lose its support
so queenie won by hikaru a very typical
idea potentially bringing the queen into
the game
is his intention here with queen g3 or
queen h4
magnus goes knight a4 and here magnus
initiates a very interesting sequence of
moves that i really really liked
i was playing title tuesday while this
game was ongoing so i was keeping an eye
on it with a corner of my eye
and now that i look at it with a fresh
pair of eyes i'm quite impressed with
how magnus handled the stage of the game
not fearing
hikaru's attack on the king's side but
rather going right after his weak pawns
on the queen side knight a4 attacks the
pawn on c3
and it's a very significant pawn because
it's the base of the pawn chain
and when you eliminate the base of the
pawn chain that's not a pawn you want to
sacrifice because the rest of the pawn
chain essentially falls to bits
which means that icaro has to defend it
with knight f3
and now magnus goes for knight b2 which
is
a very audacious move and it looks more
audacious than it is
in my in my view because it's not like
the knight's going to get
trapped here it's got a lot of escapes
it's got a4 it's got c4 it's got d3
and why is this move better than
attacking it via knight b6
the reason it's better than playing
knight back to b6
is because after knight d2 i believe
magnus had intended the move potentially
bishop d3
and at the very least it's an extra
option trading off the light squared
bishops he can also of course repeat the
position with knight a4
much as he would have been able to with
knight b6 but this gives black a couple
extra options and sure enough hikaru
tries to exploit it
with bishop g5 okay he's attacking the
queen magnus
moves the queen up and now hicaro
basically
throws his chips into the center of the
table by playing queen h4 it's very
clear that he essentially is abandoning
his queen side
and banking all of his efforts
on checkmating black on the king's side
and he's going to try to make black pay
for the absence of the dark squared
bishop ideas like bishop f6 sacking the
bishop come to mind
uh ideas such as knight g5 after word
come to mind and it's really obviously
going to be a question
of whether or not um this campaign is
going to pay off so either this game is
going to end in a black win or a white
win there seems to be no middle ground
from this point on
and it makes perfect sense to me so
magnus plays cdcd
and he takes on c4 well which he has to
ikaru repositions his queen on g4
and the idea of this move i think is
twofold first of all he's paving the way
for the pawn
to run all the way to h5 which he
attempts to do a couple moves later
which dislodges the bishop which opens
up the g5 which allows moves like bishop
f6 to happen
and that dovetails into the second idea
which is that
if you do sacrifice the bishop on f6 the
queen is going to be well positioned
to exploit the weakening of black's king
via the g-file
magnus centralizes his queen hikaru
brings
his rook into the game with okay to e1
magnus brings his own rook into the game
you can very clearly see how both
sides are essentially following their
campaign chicago on the king side magnus
on the queen side
and it's all moving inevitably towards
some sort of tactical
danum some sort of tactical climax
in which um the question is going to be
whether or not what black will be able
to beat back
white's sacrificial attack and in
general terms that's exactly what
happened so h4 by hikaru threatening h5
now it would be unthinkable to allow h5
so magnus immediately nips that in the
bud
of course this creates a weakness and
this also weakens the bishop on g6
um and magnus and this is what makes
magnus magnus
you come out ball this is what makes
magnus magnus
you know once magnus decides on a
certain course of action he doesn't look
back and he doesn't flinch
and he collects the pawn on a3 here
because he's determined that
either white's attack is going to work
or it's not and there's going to be no
middle ground
and as international master nikolai
minov used to say at least i'm going to
die with a full stomach
so what magnus is doing is that if this
attack fails
he's ensuring that he's going to be
completely winning because now he's
already up two pawns and he's got
connected passers
so he's one could say
bracing for impact by collecting as much
loot as possible
in preparation for white's attack not
succeeding i don't know if that makes
sense
but there's very little he can do here
in terms of bringing defenders
onto the king side like his king side is
as it is the queen can't come back
the bishop on g5 is slicing through
black's position not allowing the
knights are already on the queen side
it's
it's too late to try to bring them over
to the king's side
the russian expression having said a you
also have to say
b comes to mind here like he's already
started what he started
he might as well die with a full stomach
and sure enough icaru plays bishop f6
which if i've explained this well
should not surprise anybody he's trying
to rip open black's king's side
pram asks in a blitz game like this how
far do you think hikaru calculates his
attack
i would say that
you would be surprised to find that
neither side is really calculating far
at all
why is that because in a situation like
this
there are so many candidate moves to
consider
that in a blitz game they're largely
relying on their intuition
what do i mean by an abundance of
candidate moves well
first of all you have to consider gf and
certainly hikaru attempted to calculate
this move
and i think hikaru concluded that after
he takes f6
he has such an abundance of tactical
resources
that this doesn't require any deeper
calculation
now you might be saying well how the
[ __ ] excuse me how the hell
does hikaru get away with this when you
might try to do the same thing and then
the attack crashes and burns
dikaio good to see you back man does
that mean
bullet is all intuition pleasure to see
dikaio back in the chat
bullet is 95 intuition with one
exception
with one exception and
that exception is in bullet games and if
you watch my own bullet games you will
notice this
i sometimes take one or two moments i
define them as critical moments
and i take 10 seconds or so and actually
calculate
and determine my proper course of action
okay um a lot of people assume and this
is their downfall that in bullet you
have to make every move instantly but if
you actually study the legends bullet
games
hikaru people who are really have been
good at bullet for a long time you will
actually see and i've done this
that they sometimes take one or two
moments in a game and actually take five
seven seconds
to perform some very basic calculations
okay
so i want to make this point very clear
now the move bishop f6 i can bet
shahikaro played very quickly
because it's the sort of situation he's
already bitten off more than he can chew
he either does this or you know he he
might as well die it's the same
mentality magnus is having just on the
other side
if he doesn't do this he's gonna be down
two pawns for no compensation
so how do you identify these critical
moments
this would be a situation where even in
a bullet game as black
i would spend 10 seconds evaluating
whether or not i can take on f6
um because if you've determined that you
in fact can take on f6
this is a moment where you can
potentially refute the attack
let's try to unpack this for a second i
again repeat to you guys
i haven't consulted this position with a
computer so
probably everything that i tell you will
be wrong but in my opinion the fun of
game analysis is precisely
you know to try to arrive at the truth
yourself
and to discover some so let's discover
some beautiful lines here what do you
guys say
so let's try to understand what white's
threats are in this position obviously
there's the potential of a lobster
pincer checkmate um
queen f6 queen h6 pawn on f6
unfortunately while watching the clip i
did catch the computer's evaluation my
eyes could not be averted from it
and the computer says i think black is
winning after rook c3 now let's try to
figure out why that's the case
queen f4 um is the move that that needs
to be refuted
and i think i see actually the
refutation of this move do you guys
would you guys like to take a stab at
at trying to find how black prevents the
idea of queen h6
typing video has yeah i have one of my
youtube videos has a clip where i'm
typing
now king h7 is king h7 is very tempting
but it allows knight g5 check and at the
very least
white can repeat moves here with knight
f3 so king h7
cures the symptoms but not the
underlying cause
when you're trying to defend try to cure
first and foremost the underlying
cause which is the pawn on f6 it's not
queen h6 it's the pawn on f6
that you need to be attract that you
need to be looking at here in order to
attempt to root out the cause of the
attack and some of you guys are actually
saying the right move queen f5
um putting the queen in front of the
queen on f4 and after queen h6 there's
queen takes f6
and look at this bishop on g6 the unsung
hero of the defense
the queen then returns to g7 and of
course white's attack completely
saved for some hope chess ideas fizzles
out
so i believe the move queen f5 ends the
game immediately
um so that's an important thing
uh you know trying to tackle the
symptoms rather than the cause is a very
common
mistake that people make when they're
defending because they see the immediate
threat
of queen h6 and they try to stop that
one rather than understanding why queen
h6 is strong queen h6 is not strong
because there's a queen on h6 queen h6
is strong because there's a pawn on f6
sorry to to belabor the point to such an
extent why was what was the rook move
for
i think it was to immobilize the knight
so if you made any old move here such as
b5
um my guess is that white has a very
unpleasant move knight e5
uh what does 95 achieve it achieves uh
three things that i see immediately
number one
you guys now see that the window of
opportunity has closed because the rook
is defending f6
which means that this is now a much
stronger threat number two it does
attack the knight
which will we actually go ahead and take
the knight maybe not but
we don't want to just give up free
knights and third of all knight takes g6
is a very very nasty threat
because you simply penetrate through
another avenue here f takes g6 is
checkmate
and white is threatening a devastating
discovery holy smokes
is azzy he is zazzy gifting two subs to
lords kubar
and ivanovic 271 thank you so much man
appreciate it
need some water jesus so hopefully that
makes sense now queen takes d4 check
is not a scary check because the king
actually becomes
very very safe on h1 this doesn't
actually do that much for black
so hopefully that makes sense now that's
the thing with computer moves
in retrospect this makes perfect sense
but
it's difficult to like understand that
if that makes sense during the game in
the heat of the moment this looks very
scary
this looks very scary and for that
reason magnus refrained from taking on
f6
now what i said in the beginning about
magnus not playing
well this is exactly what i mean for an
idiot like me
taking not taking on f6 is totally
normal for magnus
refraining from taking on f6 speaks to
in my opinion a fundamental lack of
confidence
and belief in his defensive abilities
which has always been the mainstay
um the cornerstone of what one of the
things that makes him so great
is his ability to call his opponent's
bluff you know and calculate
seamlessly in the span of only a couple
of seconds
so magnus still won this game and he
goes knight c2
but he allows cicaro the opportunity to
complicate things with bishop d3
very very strong move in my opinion of
course a distraction sacrifice so you
cannot take the bishop because of
checkmate
now the window of opportunity for taking
the f6 bishop is closed as well
thank you banktown california for the
sub yeah i understand your question from
i think it was a little bit of both
i think the game that icaru had to win
uh with black
hikara deserves tremendous credit for
that game because
you know because of the fact that he
played the king's indian
and one with black winning with black
against magnus as i said is
herculean effort
so that window of opportunity is closed
now magnus does take on
e on e1 and i think the critical
position arose
perhaps in this situation magnus drops
his queen back
what is the purpose of this move the
purpose of this move i think
is that after bishop takes pawn takes
queen takes black is preemptively
defending the pawn on g7 and he can now
bring his queen over to f7 in
in a familiar defensive maneuver and
lend some reinforcements to the king's
side
typical magnus move now
i think that perhaps icarus should have
done something like this
and maybe dropped his queen back to g3
and prepare knight g5 i don't think any
of this works
i'm not sure exactly i heard from
someone that ikaro did have a draw
somewhere
but i'm not sure exactly where it is and
i think for a human
to find that draw is almost impossible
now magnus does play rook c3
hikaru tries to muddy things up with d5
what is the idea the idea is that he
takes d5 meets with
what move why don't you guys take a stab
at finding the idea here
what is the idea and this is a very
typical positional idea actually not
just a tactical idea
it manifests itself in a variety of
different positions it's a very classic
pawn breakthrough e6
opening up the e5 score for the night
and in this position you guys can
already see
that there's a million pieces involved
in the attack queen takes g6 is coming
in
and uh there's huge trouble here
for black so for that reason he of
course refrained
from taking on d5 and instead he drops
his rook onto c3
pinning both the bishop and the knight
okay so rookie three by hicaro
attempting
to solve the question of the pin and
free up the knight
takes takes e takes d5 this stream is
like
again but live well that's the point i'm
trying to provide analysis that will be
both
entertaining to high-level players and
accessible to low-rated players i hope
i'm succeeding
i know i make errors i learn how to do
it better
now hikaru and notice what magnus is
doing here
and i want to point out this is a very
important defensive mechanism
that everybody in this room should
take to heart okay when you're up a lot
of material
remember that you can give some of it
back in order to prevent some of the
threats don't be greedy
remember after rook three rooks e3 ed
what has magnus accomplished magnus says
he eliminated one of white's strongest
attacking pieces the one
that would have allowed hikaru to take
on g6
and at least make some inroads so now
this bishop on g6
is both uncontested and solid as a rock
appreciate it you guys very very sweet
and thank you for all the support so far
um you guys are are awesome um
really and i'll talk more about that
later but
what happens here magnus is up three
puns
uh and the bishop on g6 is solid as a
rock there's no more attack
hikaru tries to open up the e5 square
now he's four pawns down and the rest is
a matter of mopping up the attack is
over
the cairo you know is extremely
resilient and it's not that he should
have resigned here
he tried everything he could have tried
but down four pawns
with no attack we won't look at the rest
of the game i'll just very quickly play
through it
magnus finds a very nice simplifying
mechanism
to force the trade of rooks again he
uses the same technique here
uh he doesn't even give up any of his
pawns bishop takes f6
now we got a queen end game remember
even queen end games down four or five
pawns can be drawn i think i showed
charlie once uh a game that i played
against in 1900 where i drew
i [ __ ] unite queen against queen and
four pawns and three of them were
connected
so it's always possible to fall into
some perpetual but magnus
plays it very expertly centralizing his
queen stopping queen g6
and now he again gives up a bunch of his
pawns but he pushes
the most far advanced one and now he
escapes the checks
easily king comes to h4 very nice little
square
and queen e5 check boom boom boom boom
now even at the very end i guess he
could have promoted as well
but he plays this as accurately as
possible forcing the king out to the
first drink in order to promote with
check
so this is how magnus
won his game and i think where was
cicara's specific mistake i'm not
actually sure
i think hikaru someone said pointed out
that perhaps he should have gone earlier
toward the queen side
uh pardon me toward the king side maybe
queenie won immediately maybe sacking on
c4
and going bishop g5 queen g3 made a
little bit more sense
but um of course hindsight is 20 20.
and um it's very difficult to sense the
moments
when you should throw all caution to the
wind
and um you know you don't know how much
you should defend how much you should
[Music]